OH WE FIRED REGGIE!! *laughs*
Yeah, we shouldn't have fired Reggie you fuck.
MARK: Hello everyone, My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Factorio!
MARK: We made a goof, we goofed, we goofed all over the place!
MARK: We sprayed all over, we goofed all over Reggie
MARK: UMMMM.. yeah, poor Reggie, he was old but it wasn't his fault.
MARK: He was just- We weren't feeding our employees is the problem
MARK: We, yeah, we're bad bosses!
MARK: pretty much...
BOB: Basically
Mark: You know ordinarily you'd have like auto feeders, you know..
Mark: puttin' coal in these things, if you had your layout all done correctly
Mark: but apparently you do not.
Bob: Yea I don't have that set up
Mark: Yea, you do not don't cha?
Bob: H-how would you set that up?
Mark: Well basically you would have it laid out in a completely different way
Mark: then the way you do now.
Bob: Sure, sure, sure.
Bob: Sounds really good, yeah.
Mark: See... control click doesn't work!
Mark: It doesn't work.
Mark: You're a liar.                                                             Bob: Yeah it does.
Bob: Good, good good.
Bob: There it is.
Bob: You have to have it in your hand.
What... oh (Mark is stupid and just realized this)
Bob: On the hotbar at the bottom, put it in your hand in there.
Bob: just so I can quickly refill everything.
Bob: I keep it in like, the alternate hotbar...
the shift bar, or whatever.
Mark: I don't have the alternate hotbar.
Mark: Oh... the one on the right side!
Mark: Oh, you can actually research more quickbars if you feel like it. Bob: Oh no, yeah
Bob: Yeah, yeah.
Mark: By the way.
Bob: I haven't done that.
Mark: Yeah, there's no point in that because we got
Mark: advanced materials processing on the way, and now we got COPPER
Mark: Going to our giant machine of science!
Mark: It's like a, Bill Nye thing.
Mark: The science machine processing machine of science.
[Ok you worded right Mark!]
Mark: Are we, wait... why are we running out of steel.
Mark: What?
Mark: WHAT?
Mark and clip: WHAT?
Mark: More money...
Mark: Suck a cock.
Bob: Oh, there's not enough iron plates.
Bob: They're not making it all the way through anymore.
Mark: Why? Oh because power went down.
Mark: No it's fine because power went down
Mark: therefore there was a stop
Bob: Oh power went down, power went down.
Mark: Power went down. ... But it's cool
Mark: because now power is up and everything is running. So now we just need...
Mark: the copper to get to
Mark: the place and I dont know how the hell we're going to do that
Mark: I might have to move one of the science machines but
Mark: I think
Bob: I think you can,
think you can. Can't you just get copper
Bob: onto the same belt and then just let the belt
be grabable by the
copper inserter guy
Mark: If we..
made sure that the steel was only on one
side of the belt and the coppers on the other side
then yes... but..
we can do it, we can do that! we can do that. I, I
I-I there's a way we can do that
Bob: all you have
to do is change the inserters over at the steel
plate so that they all, they- the one problem
is just the inserter that i set up actually
your inserters are set up in a way so that
Mark: [markiplier noise]
they all go the the same side and mine is
ruining it.
ok so then we just- SO IF I JUST SET UP
an inserter... if I get rid of this stupid useless light
Fuck you, conveyor belt! Did I do that? No I- I always stand on the conveyor belts and slowly move
away from what I'm doing. I just I just know that
will all be on the same side copper
injected which if we were just run the
copper over on a on a transporter belt
it'll be injected [MARK: Yeees...] into the right side [Mark: Yeees... yes exactly!]
so just the overflow line that you have-
if you just run it down and I know you
want to put the underground by the road
because this road is never going to change
Just - can't you just let me have this?                            MARK: I- I'm agreeing with you right now! I'm doing the agreements
I'm saying yes, I understand your methodology for it, I get
it I get yes I get it and I get you.
You understand why I'm insane? That what you're saying? Mark: Well... yes, exactly. what I didn't want to say that you were insane I just wanted to like-
Bob: Right. I could
feel it coming, so...
Mark: [chuckles] You could feel the insanity coming or you could feel my criticism? I could *feel* you cumming-
actually don't have any underground get
you out of underground no I have
underground boss boss no don't do it like that
that's fine that's perfect
well that is perfectly right that is why
is that not good tell us what we wanted
actually it's, it's- You're right, I'm wrong, I'II
take blame for that. That is that is my fault.
see it's nice it's like you wanted it
goes around the road right appreciate
that I appreciate that I know that's not
good
this can't happen because oh wait no it
can't happen it's good it's fine it's
fine don't don't question it it's fine I
wish there was more copper I'm going to
release we can up the copper production
replaced with this lower gravity gravure
yeah actually just make the two regular
furnaces into steel furnaces in will be
much better that you had me at dude I
well this is a game for the dumb so it
still no no no no not like that I mean
saying how incredibly smart you are
so yeah I could feel it coming hey you
could feel it coming again you could
feel my good feeling coming from a mile
away I do I do I just makes me happy
inside my heart I'm here for you and
just because you have the knows you're
looking out for me you have the nose of
a shark and you can smell me come here
it means a lot there's like to clog with
conveyor we need like a smart grabber
taken a little a little little little
can overflow I think I can put it right
here and it'll be super chill and then
we'll have all the conveyor we want will
will never have to worry about getting
good very good guys will have extras yet
that one conveyor machine is really
pumped out everything that we liked it
yes I would like the gear makers like
just one gear makers pretty much enough
I didn't need to make too I just I'm
asinine and wanted it to be symmetrical
sushi ok but this is good because the
interior lupus doing finds got enough of
everything just needs more electrical
production but there's plenty of that
I'm going to take out the filter for the
copper cable and everything's gonna be
good
should be there very many answers of you
the answers are starting to come back in
on the outside
yeah because it was just too flooded so
now a lot of stuff going on look at all
this I know right it's exciting you
helped you did you did most of the work
bob you you did all this it was just
thinking work every time I way what the
fuck where the fuck is this your stepdad
and rescued the day because you have
saved everything ok Sarah crucial
research I'd like to get solar power
yeah we we got enough power power is
never again
the only direction that I think that we
need is we we could get drone bots we
need a drone bites that work for us what
we need to do is we needed ok we need
full I which advanced electronics to
robotics yeah exactly so that allows it
yeah so all this system with the
conveyors and shit this will be
irrelevant if we get like robots second
just fly the ship where we needed to go
its fuel light is probably not even
all-knowing flight is like fourth row
third from the right now we just need
engines electric engines yeah we didn't
get electric engines we need engine
electronics two engines electric engines
flight yes and then the logistics robots
will be able to transport everything
everywhere we need really I never took
into account electric engines and flight
I really like mad you suggested bail let
me try so hard to really get the air he
didn't even matter
ok so now everything is doing super cool
im just gonna have now onto the red dot
down there to the southeast that doesn't
sound good about to start covering them
it looks like okay or something
oh no oh no oh no the interior loop it's
putting copper on the 10 God because
clear in the loop I got I got smart one
all smart him hard to clear the lag a
day it's fixed everything's fixed ok
everything's hundred punches the only
thing we have is likely almost too much
because this copper box is full age of
steel wouldn't afternoon I forget the
sum of this old stuff is just hear from
like the the ancient days of the Soviet
Union and everything's been from age
five steps of the Stone Age my favorite
voters yes my age when a price that's
down age as a good that was a good show
you know this whole times like since we
started playing this game and started
talking about the logistics in my mind
like logistics like it's right there so
for some UPS is logistics
recording that's the best I could come
up with six episodes and then like to
three hours of recording justly you you
had to craft beer like yes
UPS invented flight leave me alone I
can't leave you Llodra literally in this
together we have nowhere to go except up
until like what ups made like
inventory's we're doing it
ok anyway so now we need to ok so we
received 31 Street rearing ok do you
want to go and see if that happened I
didn't just go do you want to go kill a
alien ness thing because resources that
we get these special items called alien
artifacts and deeper in the research
tree you'll see that there's something
in there for utilizing
day to go but anyway the alien artifacts
are actually used in crafting down the
road and also it's just like alien tech
somewhere in there that's yeah so
shotgun is way better than the machine
gun so I would recommend the extra
special benefit of it is you can bring a
gun turret with you planted outside of
the camp and that way whenever you get
panicked you just run back to your gun
turret it'll kill everything and
everything I need it so you can have all
of that
thank you but i wanna witness told
there's a box in the middle of deposits
got hundreds of would I there's a body
gets right here
wide it's over here in my box marked
this like an infinite these are the
boxes you babies are my boxes that's
right I made you ok then no need to
panic its cool everything's cool to get
the rest of the sides and then we're
going to put this ok everything's a
hundred and five got lots of science so
much the only thing we don't have
actually were running low on roadsides
of all things I read science is really
shitty I don't know why we can fix that
awful ok good system for that why did
you allow my sister to be the one that
we continue to use the system for this
but I could very quickly make us a red
science loop energy super easy and I
could do it in no time do you want me to
do that for you let's just disassembled
this road signs this is making its not
making anything major building shit
around can we use our our iron and
copper supply line
Splitter to split that into two lines
and then use that to supply both of our
science most definitely we can cause
that'd be an intelligent use of the
tools that we have right life like as if
in like such as the I ran like all of
that is it just gonna split perfectly
one into copper in 10 I think it split
into two identical rows of whatever it
is helpful i think thats crafting a
whole as I will make it then i'm ok ok
ok I have no idea I had that idea and
then I did it I'm so proud of you bob
that works great you are good at this
gave the job and we got a supply line
you do the hard part I I made the
splitting of the supply lines thanks ok
so this is super easy it's super easy do
I just need three more
standing right here as you go for a swim
you do whatever you gonna do whatever it
is it's super easy to do because there's
really nothing to it you just get these
three working on signs of power lines
later not yet don't put them in yet we
don't need him yet it's so i mean like
they go away from I do this a lot okay
yeah that's what you do when you're on
your own you just basically putting
poles down in the taking
ok so the cool thing about this is the
only thing that needs to be on the belt
on the inside is copper copper and years
of gears need to be on one sideline
copper needs to be on the other side and
then it's literally unlimited on what
you can do so such as the I ran this
will go like this
covering the copper don't you worry
about it
ok you just bring that over bring it
over a year
ok cool thank you you are a delight to
fit into this line right here
day ok so here's what's gonna be
complicated one of the we're gonna have
long handles block there's a lake in the
way
production is on know this god damn
piece of shit laid back to the lake with
our guns oh my god I can we get rid of
this helped make this locker I just
gotta move everything over one
on son of a bitch your life is so hard
yeah alright we're actually out of time
for this episode but this will be done
next time we come back understand
understood ok everyone's happy about it
Thank you everybody so much for watching, and as always, I will see YOU in the next video. Buh bye!